The real way to make a
difference --
Sheila:
5-6-7-8, to the Right!
♪♪
-- is to make a fortune.
Rose:
Physical is southern California,
1980's, aerobics, big hair,
bad marriage. The dawn of a new
day.
Are you finally ready to make that
campaign video?
I'm ready to make a fortune.
♪♪
When we meet Sheila, she is at a
very dark moment
Annie:
in her emotional life.
She's been in the shadows of a
Annie:
really dynamic and charismatic
husband.
And there's this seed inside
her that wants more than that.
Babe, we all gotta do our
part.
Are you getting signatures?
No, I'm the candidate.
Sheila and Danny, both
individually want something
more.
Rory:
Danny wants to become a
politician,
Rory:
Sheila is trying to claim her
independence in society.
For her it's about ownership,
it's about independence.
Rose:
Sheila is a unique
heroine because she's an anti-heroine really.
Whose side are you on?
I'm on my side.
Annie:
Sheila's suffering from body
dysmorphia and bulimia.
And that causes all kinds of
fallout in her life.
Rose:
A big part of Sheila's story is
her illness
Rose:
with food.
And it's an illness that women
have that women don't talk about,
a lot.
I struggled with eating
disorders through much of my
life.
Annie:
So I wanted to explore how
divided women often feel projecting
Annie:
a certain look and personality
on the outside, but having
Annie:
something much darker and
secretive on the inside.
Everybody has inner voices that
we try to temper, and with
Sheila,
Rose:
you get kind of this insight
and I love that.
Sheila:
(You're short, round, lumpy,
nobody wants you)
Stop it!
It's such a great, unique
perspective on how women talk to
themselves.
Dierdre:
And the complexity of female
friendships.
Yeah you weren't listening to me
because I'm a boring fat
housewife, who's like why do you....
-No, no, no, don't say that, you
look great.
Oh that, thank you. It's a new
dress.
I'm sorry this class is full.
There's plenty of space back
here.
With Sheila and Bunny...
Della:
I both hate her and want to
destroy her,
but I also really want to be her
friend and love her. (Laughs)
Della:
So...It's about these
dualities.
You have to press power.
Thanks.
(Click)
♪♪
It's like the contrast of these
two sides of her.
Rose:
It's the life of Sheila and her
domestic life.
Putting on a face for everybody
and then
the life of her discovering
aerobics.
♪♪
Sheila:
It's special, and it makes me
feel...powerful.
♪♪
Her idea to have women
find power
Annie:
through physical strength,
that's the revolution that she's enacting.
I ate a batch of oatmeal cookies
one by one while the sun came
up.
You can't do anything about that
but you can change this moment.
Right now...if you move.
♪♪
We tried to really take aerobics
seriously
Annie:
and show what it did to empower
women in the 80's.
Every ugly thought you've ever
had about yourself, let it fuel
you!
Punch, punch, punch,
punch, punch, punch, punch!
Annie:
The way that we dramatize this
power inside Sheila,
is through this really dynamic
movement of the camera.
There's this momentum that
starts to happen
as she escalates into this high
that she gets from aerobics.
That becomes her passion.
♪♪
Craig Gillespie, who directed
the pilot had this very strong
vision.
The creative design of this has
been so collaborative
Dierdre:
in terms of establishing 1981.
Such an interesting time in
fashion
because it's just coming out of
the 70's into the 80's.
Rose:
So it's a really sweet spot.
I remember first trying on the
wig and and going "I can't
wear this" and then by the end
I'm like "Bigger, bigger,
bigger!"
(Laughing)
On my God, you look amazing.
So do you, those colors.
Rory:
I mean getting dressed up in
clothes from 1981
and have my hair look like this
is wildly fascinating to me.
Rory: But to have it be 10
episodes of a show that are very
entertaining
Rory:
and actually about something
meaningful is awesome.
I couldn't had done any of this
without you, you know that
right?
Annie:
I can't talk about this show
anymore without talking about Rose.
She's surpassed any expectation
I could've had.
Annie:
She doesn't hold anything back.
♪♪
Rose:
We didn't want to pull any
punches.
Rose:
And that's what makes the show
interesting and a bit dangerous.
♪♪
Let's do this thing!